er werde ja nun bald vor dem endgültigen
Richter seines Lebens stehen als sein
treuer Begleiter georg genzw war ein
Anfang 2022 diese Zeilen zum
Missbrauchskandal vorträgt weil es der
hochbetagte Benedikt im eritus selbst
gesundheitlich nicht mehr kann klingt es
wie ein geistiges Testament
dunkle Schatten hatte das Münchner
missbrauchsgutachten auf das Wirken
Josef Ratzingers geworfen die
Vergangenheit holte ihn einen langen
nach seinem Rückzug als Papst Benedikt
der 16 dem wohl mutigsten Schritt seines
Pontifikats das am 19 April 2005 begann
kardinale Ratzinger
Josef Ratzinger wird der 265 Papst der
Kirchengeschichte
ein Deutscher auf dem Stuhl Petri
geboren 1927 in Marktl am Inn
in Freising beginnt seine geistliche
Laufbahn hier wird er 1951 zum Priester
geweiht gemeinsam mit seinem Bruder
Georg
[Musik]
als Theologieprofessor macht der
schnellkarriere wird später Erzbischof
von München und Freising
der Gang von hier in die Ewige Stadt sei
ihm nach eigenen Worten schwergefallen
Johannes Paul II macht ihn zum perfekten
der Glaubenskongregation auch als Papst
bleibt der Theologieprofessor und doch
kann er begeistern Jubel beim
Weltjugendtag in Köln und auch bei
seiner Reise in die bayerische Heimat
eine theologische Vorlesung in
Regensburg jedoch wird zu schweren
diplomatischen Krise ein Zitat über den
Islam empört die muslimische Welt
auch die Begnadigung der Bischöfe der
Pius-Bruderschaft wird zum Skandal als
Holocaustleugnung in Williamsons bekannt
werden der Papst gesteht Fehler ein
fühlt sich missverstanden
während seines Pontifikats sitzt er
stets auf Aussöhnung und Dialog mit dem
Judentum besucht das ehemalige
Vernichtungslager in Auschwitz
in Israel die Gedenkstätte ja verschem
er verurteilte jede Leugnung oder
Relativierung des Holocaust
zu einer der größten Herausforderungen
wird der Umgang mit sexualisierter
Gewalt in der katholischen Kirche
systemisches Versagen zeichnet sich ab
weltweit Benedikt empfindet tiefes
Mitgefühl Charme und Bedauern über jeden
einzelnen Fall doch das geht vielen
nicht weit genug zu lange habe die
Kirche weggesehen mehr Täter als Opfer
geschützt
seinen überraschenden Rücktritt im
Februar 2013 begründete er mit
schwindenden Kräften Gerüchte über
Intrigen im Vatikan die war die
leaksaffäre all das ließ er zurück als
er sich am 28 Februar 2013 per
Hubschrauber nach castellgerndorfer
begab ich bin einfach nur noch ein
Pilger der die letzte Phase seiner
Pilgerreise auf dieser Erde antritt
sagte er
oder
mit diesen Worten verabschiedete sich
benedikt der 16 von den Gläubigen denn
der Mann der einst Josef Ratzinger aus
Marktl am Inn war blieb bis zu seinem
irdischen Ende im vatikanischen Exil
hochbetagt und gebrechlich reist er noch
einmal nach Deutschland um Abschied zu
nehmen von seinem älteren Bruder Georg
und von seiner bayerischen Heimat damit
ging für Joseph Ratzinger vor seinem
eigenen Abschied noch ein Herzenswunsch
in Erfüllung